les amène en voiture. Comme on
va voir dans le ree
sont 2 policiers finalement qui
en ont payé le prix ultime.
- Ce matin, une marée de
policiertrick pour rendre
hommage à un des leurs.
Cela fait une semaine que
le NYPD, la police de New York,
est en deuil.
les funérailles de Jason Rivera,
22 ans. Les policiers ont
été tués par balles après avoir
répondu à un appel
Ils allaient au secours d'une
mère qui avait une altercation
avec son fils.ontre
ces tueurs, et nous n'allons pas
perdre",perdre",perdre",perdre"e
Eric Adams, lui-même ancien
policier.
une véritable onde de choc chez
les policiers. Ces
faisaient partie de la relève.
"Je me sens très mal, dit Keith
policier, c'est une partie
de moi qui est parux."
En deux ans, le nombre
nts impliquant des armes
à feu a doublé à New York.
Dans les quartiers de Bronx,
Brooklyn, Harlem, les armes
circulent impunément.
"Les gens ont faim, dit-il.
Il n'y a plus de t
dans un état de désespoir
et ils cdes actes
désespérés", dit-elle.
L'hiver rude cettr refroidir ri
les esprits.(sirène)
"La pandémie a vraiment-il.
Il y a beaucoup de frustration.
Les gens ont perdu leur emploi,
certains se sont fait évincer
de l'inflation, tout cela est
stressant."
Et ce stress se manifeste dans
la rue. À Harlem, durant notre
par balle en plein après-midi;md
à ses blessures.
"Les ar
la ville en grand nombre", nous
dit Iesha Sekou, qui dirige
l'organi Corner Corner Corner Cr
Ressources.
"Parfoibox
contre une arme. Les jeunes
peuvent même commander
construire une arme à feu
de leur sous-sol."
"On essaie de les récupérer
avant que la rue n
charge", dit-elle.
"Notre rôle, c'est d'intervenir
une désescalade de la violence.t
provenir de n'importe où
et n'importe quandns qui monns ,
ils me disent on ne va plus
prendre le subway parce qu'ils
ont peur, voilà.
uartier de
Brooklyn, un autre affrontementr
les ressources policières pour
combattre la violence.
"Nous ne pensons pas en terme
de renforcement po
Mark Griffith.
"Les gens vivent de la
détresse, dit-il. En ajoutant
des policiers, on rendla situats
sécuritaire et plus violente."
Et pour beaucoup ce qui est
violent aussi, c'est la levée du
moratoire sur les expulsions
locataires, il y a deux
semaines. 200 000 personnes
risquent de se retrouver sans
abri.
"Si tu n'as pas à manger, dit-
elle, en plus si tu perds ton
logement et avec des problè
de santé mentale, tu perds
espoir." Selon elle, il faut
investir dans la prévention.
Même si cette recrudescence
de la vi
les proportions de celle
des années 80, bien
des Newyorkais craignent
qu'elle soit là pour rester.
Ici Azeb Wolde-Giorghis,
Radio-Canada, New